when I was single I would say the
majority of my time and attention went
to like girls in terms of just headspace
texting organizing dates a lot of my
mental bandwidth even if it wasn't ours
but like in between time went to that
and the moment we got married it was
like all of this attention of like
something else could happen was just
gone and then it was just us and this
business like we went from making a few
hundred thousand dollars a month to a
few million a month 12 months later like
it was just like we were both like
you're in I'm in let's go and so just
having that security and that knowledge
like you're my person for the
foreseeable future it just washed away
all of this attention that came back to
focusing on the main thing